bonjour lima la manifestation est
terminée
et oui tout à fait mais les
manifestations est bien terminée ça a
été très rapide du reste le
rassemblement a tourné court en milieu
d'après midi il ne restait en réalité
que quelques milliers de personnes
réunies dans ce parc du cinquantenaire
où je me trouve actuellement le reste
des manifestants ont été dispersés manu
militari par des forces de l'ordre
pléthorique par de très nombreux tirs de
gaz lacrymogènes et de canons à eau la
manifestation donc terminée on a pu
assister aux arrestations à quelques
arrestations de personnes qui refusaient
encore de vider les lieux les
échauffourées quand elles ont débuté
très vite après l'arrivée du cortège
cortège dans lequel on pouvait voir de
très nombreux manifestants très remontés
et prêts à en découdre on s'y attendait
un peu du reste a vu l'ampleur de la
manifestation les organisateurs
tablaient sur cent mille personnes et on
peut dire que le pari semble avoir été
tenu des manifestants venus de toute
l'europe à l'appel du collectif european
council for freedom et de centaines
d'autres organisations on pouvait voir
des drapeaux belges néerlandais
allemands italiens polonais est
également français puisque des gilet
jaune hexagonaux avaient fait le
déplacement notamment du nord et de
l'est de la france et je vous propose
d'écouter certains des manifestants
présents à cette manifestation
aujourd'hui
je défends mes droits de l'homme j'ai
été exclue de ma communauté le monde
sous prétexte que je n'ai pas voulu
participer à l'expérimentation vaccinale
je peux combattre le virus tout seul
je pense que chacun doit avoir la
possibilité de choisir de faire le
vaccin ou pas nous devons être libres de
nos choix comme toujours
je suis pas gros le vaccin je suis
content ce certificat dont celui vers
code je peux pas le voir si que c'est
inhumain et on voit qu'on pourra insérer
peut-être plusieurs choses tu payes pas
désavantager pas des infos d'un mauvais
citoyens
pressés
pour la liberté
l'objectif de cette mobilisation m donc
la pression sur les institutions sur les
autorités européennes aient tenté
d'infléchir les politiques sanitaires
appliquée par les différents
gouvernements à travers le continent ce
rassemblement s'est d'ailleurs tenue à
quelques centaines de mètres seulement
de la commission européenne à
rassemblement donc qui comme ceux des
semaines précédentes à bruxelles s'est
conclue par des affrontements entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre merci
beaucoup guimard aussi pour toutes ces
précisions en direct donc de cette
manifestation contre les restrictions
sanitaires qui s'est achevée